- So, what do you each remember
from like the very first time
that y'all played together?
Was it like awkward
or like you knew right
away it was gonna work?
- Well, Natalie had joined
the band, a previous lineup,
and so Martie and I were
very, like, nervous, like,
"Well, she rehearsed all the
songs and knew all the songs."
Natalie was just like,
"Oh, I've got this, y'all."
(laughing)
She had this confidence
and Martie and I were just like,
"Oh my gosh, oh my gosh,"
but Natalie brought this humongous pad
with her lyrics on it.
and we'd just flip it in between songs.
- We played these two
clubs outside of Houston.
- Yeah.
- And I was just...
(laughing)
- Next.
- Bend down, turn the page.
(laughing)
- Oh my God,
do you have a problem with lyrics?
I do.
- No, but I had
to learn 22 songs in seven days.
I would just listen with headphones and...
- And learned to yodel.
- Walk around.
- I had never yodeled before.
(laughing)
That's a lot.
- I know.
- Oh my gosh.